being a lab animal might actually make
you less useful for experiments research
animals tend to become obese have weak
immune systems and are more susceptible
to cancer and that's before the
experiments begin only one in nine drugs
that work on lab animals ever succeeds
in human clinical trials and labs often
struggle to reproduce each other's
results we don't treat these animals
like humans we don't give them the
variety of life that people have and
some people are saying that's why these
drugs are not translating to people and
so the question is is the environment we
house these animals in the problem lab
animals typically live in barren
conditions a small plastic box few if
any companions and that's about it and
there's a reason for this for decades
scientists thought that the smaller the
number of variables keeping variety to a
minimum the more repeatable the
experiments and the stronger the results
but growing research suggests that this
approach may have backfired some
researchers are pushing to enrich the
lives of the creatures in their care and
experiments are starting to show that
such enrichments not only benefit
animals but science as well in 2000
researchers in australia added a bunch
of enrichment to Mouse cages so things
like colored balls cardboard to chew on
and play with and what they found was
these mice were much less likely to
develop symptoms of a Huntington's like
disease than mice housed in much more
standard bare and KJ before this work
everyone thought Huntington's was 100
percent genetic the team has gone on to
show similar results in rodent models of
autism Alzheimer's and depression a few
years ago researchers at Ohio State
developed what the lead researchers
daughter called Disneyland for mice and
what the reason she called it this was
this is a very large Mouse enclosure and
it had all these things you don't find
in a standard Mouse cage and what they
found is that mice that lived in this
environment were eighty percent less
likely to develop certain cancers than
mice housed in a much more standard
housing a stimulating environment seemed
to activate the mouse's hypothalamus
a region of the brain known to affect
everything from mood to cancer
proliferation there are some skepticism
out there about enrichment first of all
there's the concern about cost and
resources and researchers worried about
compromising the reproducibility from
experiment to experiment yes maybe
they'll make animals happier but they're
not going to have any big impact on the
translate ability of drugs that work in
these types of animals to drugs that
work in people to provide hard science
on the effects of enrichment an unusual
program at the University of Michigan
called real is determining which
enrichments work and don't work for
various lab animals and then
systematically exploring how research
results are affected if we can give them
companions to live with toys to interact
with puzzles to solve then they are
going to physiologically be a lot more
like wild animals rather than these what
some people think are these very kind of
unnatural systems in the lab as the
researchers dig for answers to these
questions one day we may see lab animals
and enriched conditions as a rule rather
than the exception for both the sake of
science and the animals themselves
[Music]